[Music]
What is a Universal Set The Universe is Something That Contains Everything You Can Think
of So Does That Mean The Universal
Set is a Set that Contains Everything Yes It Does But It Should Be
Suitable But What is Suitable Look at these
three  Sets Set a Which is a set of all x true that
x is a student of class
5a This set will have all students of
class 5a as its
elements are similar Lets set b Which
is a set of
all
5b and set c which is a set of all
This case would be the set of L is true that a
student of class of this is where it gets
interesting you could have said the real set is
of L students in S and set of all
students in the world but that would not be
Correct The set of all students of class
five is more suitable It means that u is
like the main set and a b and c are parts
of it Every student of class 5a will
definitely be a part of the set of
students of class five in mathematical
terms  We can say that set a is a proper
subset of the universal set Remember for a to be a
proper subset of u they have to be at least
one element in yet is not present
in
a Similarly sets b and c are also proper
subsets of the universal  Set So L The sets
under consideration should be proper subsets of the
universal set Here's another example Consider the
segment a f Looks like this It has two
points in between point p and
point q
Just like the previous example Consider
three sets Here let's set d  b the set of all
x true that x is a point on the segment
a This set will contain every
point that lies here in this range
And let f
be the set
of all
Point on segment A and remember every
set under consideration will be a proper subset
of the universal
[music]
set
B.